good morning Hank it's Friday it's
actually morning for one sense the
coffee I love it when the coffee's done
I have a letter for your 15 year old
cell today but first in your video on
Wednesday you talked about lexical gaps
like the fact that in Romanian there is
no word for shallow and in English we
don't have a word for people who aren't
virgins turns out by the way that there
is a word in Romanian for people who
aren't virgins but anyway it seemed to
me that we need to plug that lexical gap
and then plug it again Inc sorry there
was jokes like that that won me a prince
award anyway Hank as you pointed out on
Twitter the best antonym for Virgin
suggested in comments by far was verge
out but Hank with the non-virgin lexical
gap really made me think why is that
like our obsession with sexual purity is
such that once you are no longer this
thing you are indescribable which is
exactly what I want to talk to your 15
year old self about that won't be
awkward but first also in Wednesday's
video you said also dump your girlfriend
I don't know who your girlfriend is I
don't know how much you like her but
dump her right now that I'm calling Fran
my girlfriend from when I was 15
duh she called back hello hi Fran
he made a video saying that I should
dump whoever I was dating when I was 15
which was you so ah this is gonna be
awkward for both of us
because we're both married but I don't
think it's gonna work out
Oh
I mean it's partly like you not being
attracted to people of my gender I think
we could still be friends you're always
so nice about everything that that's
going on in nerdfighteria it's very I
always notice when you like retweet me
and stuff it's really nice of you well
she seemed devastated here's what I want
to say a 15-year old Hank it's not that
big of a deal
sexuality is important but it's
certainly not the only interesting or
important thing happening to you right
now 15-year old Hank both you and I live
in worlds that tell
there are only two important things one
is the acquisition of goods and the
other is either the acquisition or
avoidance of sex but Hank it turns out
that the question of who's a virgin and
whose average out is not the most
interesting question and the romantic
relationships in your life are not the
only important relationships as I give
this advice I realize that it is not
intended for fifteen-year-old Hank it is
intended for fifteen-year-old John 15
year old Hank you're doing great and if
you're watching this the only thing
you're probably thinking is is that a my
little pony in the background yes yes it
is 15 year old Hank check this out in
the future you're going to write songs
and people are going to paint ponies
about your songs which your brother will
then steal some things never change
Hank I'll see you on Monday